Here are a few examples where
ads are used fairly effectively.
You could see here a banner ad.
Banner ad are images based
advertisements that often appear
in the side, top, or
bottom section of a website.
They use PCC, paper click model,
In which advertisers pay a fee each
time a user clicks on this ad.
You can see here on the verge,
that Spotify is actually taking quite
a lot of real estate over the top.
If we scroll down,
we can see another ad over here.
And in most cases,
if we continue scrolling,
down to the bottom we can see
another ad just over here.
Another example would be the Huffington
Post, and you can see here another ad.
And another example in Yahoo Finance
would be actually two ads one for
their mobile app and the other very
prominently on the right side.